I know it's a heartbreak but and I know
that maybe Veronica didn't make your
favorite decisions this season but you
have to understand if everything was
perfect and there was no conflict you
wouldn't have a show there would be
nothing to watch if I know but if first
of all I will address one thing
specifically a lot of people were upset
when Veronica did not accept a marriage
proposal from Logan and I was a little
bit shocked at that because I I'm very
happily married and I'm like the first
person to be like I love my kids and I'm
Suzy homemaker but I also know that's
not the right decision for everyone
because everyone's heart is different
and I don't think Veronica story has to
end in a happy marriage like we're over
this idea of John Cusack holding a
boombox outside our windows some women
don't want to get married and some men
don't want to get married and that's
okay and Veronica didn't have good
examples of marriage and she's isn't
ready to commit and I for one and
playing her was like I respect that
decision so I think it would have been
too easily tied up in a beautiful bow if
she had said sure I accept your marriage
proposal now my life is great because I
have the love of my life
she still got a lot to work through and
I hope that we'll get to see it
on-screen again people forgive us I hope
so
[Music]
[Applause]